another thing dr bright is not allowed  to do with the foundation no giant  robots the foundation has been required  to use some seemingly unusual methods of  containing anomalies over the years the  polymorphic humanoid is kept in her  containment by a collection of dogs for  example there have been sugar  substitutes vats of acid vhs players and  more but one thing is certain we will  never employ the use of giant robots no  matter how many times dr bright tells  everyone to watch pacific rim or any  other piece of media that features them  we do not trust dr bright with giant  robot technology nor is it considered  the most efficient use of foundation  resources no dr bright not even on your  birthday okay except the dragon slayer  and gypsy danger i actually really like  pacific rim